buckland athletic FC first team had a
very good season last year and finished
second in the highly contested western
league premier division going into the
last weekend of the season they were
still in with a chance of winning the
league but just fell short aside from
playing the club is a very well-run
football club and recently engaged in
the local community with their ten-year
plan on how they can really embrace the
whole community and future development
that will soon surround the club chudley
cricket club in particular their first
eleven have had a wonderful season in
Devon cricket B division they've just
been crowned B division champions and
will play next season in Devon a
division this is a truly remarkable
turnaround of form as last season they
narrowly avoided relegation to the C
division they have a wonderful youth
program superb location and a proactive
committee what other sport could field
such a wide span of Ages in their first
eleven and win their league ranging from
16 to 68 timnath RFC first team last
season was Timoth RFC's 140 eighth
anniversary as a rugby club and they
celebrated in style by winning both the
western counties Westley and also the
Devon intermediate cup beats
unprecedented in the club's long history
adding both competitions together the
team won 28 matches losing only three
they scored 1107 points including a
hundred and sixty tries conceding only
418 points